here we go another day another week
another obi-wan video and before we get
started i'm going to give some love to
part of my breakfast that would be ag-1
by athletic greens which has each scoop
packed with probiotics and vitamins
which helps in your daily physical
health routine as well as brain health
you can get creative blend it together
with ingredients of your choice have
yourself a solid breakfast shake right
there so click the link below and get
yourself a year's supply of vitamin d3
k2 and 5 travel packs with your first
purchase and now on to talking about
episode 4 of obi-wan kenobi that's a
spoiler alert for episode 4 of obi-wan
also spoiler alert for episode 3 because
you know better safe than sorry so at
the end of episode 3 of obi-wan kenobi
darth vader and obi-wan they clashed
lightsabers vader force-pulled obi-wan
kenobi through his least favorite thing
in the galaxy
sand into his second least favorite
thing in the galaxy which is fire
burning him you're like all right this
is going to be the aftermath man what is
obi-wan thinking there's gotta be a lot
going through his mind and everyone of
course was thinking where's leia well
let me tell you where leia is obi-wan
leia is doing exactly what leia does
she's getting captured i know twice in
one series it's crazy get used to it
that shit's gonna happen and get in a
new hope this is one of those moments i
can't help but look at this episode and
be like
dude there should have been a lot more
emotional weight like there should be a
lot more emotional weight in an obi-wan
series dealing with obi-wan anakin
obi-wan and vader you know should be in
here more obi-wan kenobi just clashed
lightsabers with his former apprentice
his old friends who in this universe
they've set up in the ob1 series he
thought was dead for 10 years i know
that wasn't the way it was before but in
the series like oh i guess he thought
anakin died on mustafar
but he's alive and now he just learned
that this should have been the episode
where obi-wan's licking his wounds like
is all of this worth it he's so terrible
then qui-gon's force ghost can be like
there's always hope will be one quick on
could also be like also why did you not
keep up on your force powers you had one
job so in this episode leia's been taken
to the super secret inquisitor base and
they go to this inquisitor base to get
her out i like that in terms of
atmosphere i always like it when good
guys are in bad guy territory and
they're alone they're isolated there's
no help coming
until the ends because that freaked me
out i was like whoa snow speeders
now i'm kind of pissed i'm not pissed
for the reasons you might be thinking
i'm pissed because in every star wars
game i've ever played snow speeders
never had the ability to hover i could
do that i'm talking like idle hover
without moving forward like a helicopter
i suppose they would have to be able to
some degree that's how they would take
off but the concept does kind of break
the battle of hoff to some degree yes
makes it a lot easier for the good guys
like all right so the whole elaborate
toe cable thing and tripping these
things just hover on their backs behind
the sweet spot and just blast them in
the neck all we got to do is get behind
them
simple so i like the general atmosphere
of the place don't know about
obi-wan stumbling onto the set of dexter
new blood i don't know about inquisitors
what
it doesn't really explain but
inquisitors are keeping their first kill
as trophies i guess that or they're just
keeping all jedi kills as trophies
they're gonna have to make a lot more
room it doesn't really explain it was
just weird i just i don't like the idea
of darth vader or inquisitors or whoever
keeping jedi bodies as trophy kills just
kind of changes the logistics of the
extermination of the jedi but to be fair
i might have misread it could be
something that's pulled from the books
or the comic books and it might mean a
completely different thing saw that in
the comment section of my previous lb1
video someone was like clearly jeremy's
never read the darth vader comics this
is like a laughing emoji there i mean
i haven't
secrets out never hidden it i mean i've
read the first few issues of it like the
trade also was dr aphra still alive or
did she die
i know i kind of like to see her vader's
super sexy friend was just kind of
hanging out with him anyhow yeah i
haven't read the comics i shouldn't have
to read the comics in order to ingest
the show also for talking about things i
liked in this episode are like obi-wan
doing stealth kills that's actually
pretty sweet it's a completely dark room
except for little leia who's in this
super torture chair and these two storm
troopers then a lightsaber just ignites
slices one down and then goes away and
then ignites slices the other one down i
was like that's pretty sweet these are
the tactics he learned in the clone wars
it's all coming back to him now think
how much better he'd be if he didn't get
rusty over 10 years like a dumbass also
i laughed my ass off in the scene i
laughed and then rewound the scene to
watch the scene again to laugh at the
scene again when the two stormtroopers
were about to arrest the imperial
officer who's actually good you know
working with obi-wan got him into this
place and she slaps the stormtrooper
helmet and she's kind of like
and then the stormtrooper was like oh
man my helmet it should have been like
boom why did you
do you see that she just slapped me in
the helmet when i was wearing my helmet
did did she slap you too oh i'm conor
you know around the bell a little bit
she got me good right why would she do
that did she think that would work you
think clone troopers ever got slapped in
the head i don't know well she's dead
now so i guess it doesn't matter i don't
know it was funny if you didn't catch it
watch it again it's hilarious but the
big thing in this episode is riva is
interrogating leia and i gotta say
riva is not a menacing presence this is
the episode that solidified i know a lot
of people in the first episode just like
picked that right away like ah nope not
buying it i was like all right let's
give it some time we'll see how the
character grows there hasn't been much
character growth however the episode did
come to pass in which riva gets her shot
to be that scary menacing presence and
she couldn't even shake a ten-year-old
which there i get it you wanna
make all the little girls out there who
look up to princess slay you want them
to be like yeah she's tough i'm gonna be
tough but sometimes in order to properly
craft an intimidating menacing or
otherwise scary character or scene you
got to scare the living [ __ ] out of the
kids i'm just saying i mean yeah when
she was in the chair about to get
tortured then she started screaming for
help but she wasn't scared of riva it
was the chair it could have been otto
the garbage man about to push torture or
whatever the button says to activate the
chair but when it came to facetime
interrogation it was just reba it was
just
you know what it reminded me of it
reminded me of spider-man homecoming
when spider-man's trying to be
intimidating to
donald glover at the end of it after
spider-man is completely not
intimidating donald glover goes just a
word of advice you gotta get better at
this part of the job it was like that
only didn't try to be funny tried to
actually pull it off to me it looked
like inquisitors apparently play good
cop bad cop and riva's always good cop
but this is the time she's working alone
she's going it on her own so she gets to
be bad cop
oh she has no practice at it she's not
good at it and in the end riva puts a
tracking device on leia's little prop
from batteries not included droid i feel
like all of this happened to explain how
leia and a new hope knew they were being
tracked because it's happened to her
before which sounds really ridiculous to
say it out loud like why would you make
a plot point in an ob one series to
explain that but we've seen that happen
before and whatever movie or show has to
explain how they knew that how they had
those powers of observation a decade
later maybe that's not what they're
doing
but probably is like maybe lay's just
smart maybe someone who's in a rebellion
thinks that way even when a smuggler
doesn't and probably should in the end
it looks like they have two episodes to
wrap all this stuff up i like the
location i like the feel of good guys
being in bad guy territory however this
should have had a lot more emotion for
obi-wan
just squaring off with his old friend
who tortured people in front of him and
broke their necks and then dragged him
to fire i'm sorry one back and forth
shot in a bathtu tank just it's not
enough for me but it's kind of you know
it's the show right it's what it is this
whole show should have had more emotion
and it hasn't and hey i got a real
surprise for you tomorrow i'm reviewing
a movie like an actual movie but episode
4 of obi-wan kenobi have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you